Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
The Loki season 2 finale just aired and is probably
one of the best things Marvel has done this year.
And just in general,
like one of the best series they have ever done.
Loki is literally saving the entire MCU
like the multiverse itself.
Within the context of the story.
All the movies, all the shows.
But he's also kind of saving the MCU in real life.
because it has been having a real hard time lately.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
also because the Loki series just ended.
I'll give away a couple of copies of the Loki
Blu ray during this video.
Careful for spoilers from the Loki Season two finale
if you haven't seen it yet.
But at the end of the finale
we learned that he who remains orchestrated
the events of Loki's life
since Avengers Endgame when he became a variant.
The younger version of Loki from that first Avengers
movie escaped in his whole goal,
like his ultimate grand plan, was to push Loki
to evolve his powers into something
more like the God of stories where he could time travel
without the need for technology
the way that he does in the comics in control
time around him.
like he was also able to stop time for just Sylvie
when he spoke with he who remains
making him more powerful than all the Kings,
the Council of Kings,
because they all need technology to do what he's doing
naturally with his own biological power.
and he who remains entire gambit, like his entire plan,
hinged on pushing Loki into a position to be able
to rule over just the sacred timeline that he created
using the loom in that one single timeline itself.
Without the need for technology.
basically he remains was trying to create a supreme
being in this Loki who could manage things
so that he could either die or just leave
because essentially he didn't want the job anymore.
so Loki would take his place theoretically and become
Loki, who remains,
which he kind of does at the end of the episode.
biology chose a third option.
He wanted to save all of his friends,
all of his loved ones, like his brother Thor, in
all the different universes, all the variants
of his brother, all the variants of his friends do
they would have either been killed
when the loom exploded again because it kept doing that
over and over and over again.
When the Loom resets, the sacred timeline,
which we learned was actually its true purpose.
he remains secretly engineered to erase
all branch timelines no matter what they did to it.
and each time it would overload, it would just
reset back to baseline and it would blow up the TVA.
In the process, he remains would just rebuild the TVA
over and over again.
Each time Loki chose to destroy the loom itself
so that the wider multiverse could exist.
But because this infinitely growing multiverse
with all these different timelines couldn't survive
without something like the loom He discovered
that he had evolved the ability to reinvigorate
the timelines with his magic, with his power,
which is why it's green.
a lot of people also asking
if this is why the time stone is green.
Marvel definitely
didn't plan that going into Infinity War in Endgame,
like the creation of the Infinity Stones
just in general is more of a happy coincidence.
Like they didn't always plan on using Loki this way in
they decided that he was going to use Green Magic
way, way back when the first Thor movie came out.
so it's one of those cool retroactive Easter eggs.
Kind of like Spider-Man during Iron Man 2.
Like they didn't plan for Spider-Man
to be this little kid.
but when they were promoting Spider-Man Homecoming,
Tom Holland suggested
the idea that he was that little kid in Kevin Feige.
He liked it so much.
He basically made it canon on the spot.
but basically, Loki is now the gardener
feeding his green energy
into all these timelines, making them healthy timelines
again, in effect, scaled up infinitely for the ever
growing multiverse, fashioning his own pattern
with all the timelines
to make it look more like a depiction of the world
tree from Norse mythology.
Notice the timelines up at the top depicting
the branches are still moving around.
Seemingly.
That's because the timelines
are continuing to grow as they branch out even further.
the whole idea here too,
is that we're looking at this in the fourth dimension.
It's like a higher dimension.
That's why Loki can physically grab timelines
like they're ropes.
so he's continuing to exist in this higher dimension
using the remains of he who remains Citadel
and his old chair,
which you referenced earlier in the episode,
which he refashioned into his golden throne
that he was born for.
He was born to do something
but it turns out his glorious
purpose is way more cosmic,
way bigger than he ever thought.
Basically, he's
continuously feeding the branches
of all these timelines, his green magic, acting
kind of like a celestial gardener, keeping the tree
that is the multiverse, quote unquote, healthy.
Now, there are a billion questions
at the end of the episode,
like they raise more questions than they answer.
What happens next with the Loki character, Tom
Hiddleston implied in a recent interview that they film
Loki Season two to be the culmination of his 14 year
arc as the character it all comes full circle.
it's the conclusion to season two.
It's also the conclusion to seasons one and two.
It's also the conclusion to six films and 12 episodes
and 14 years of my life.
this very ominous sounding.
A lot of people heard that and assumed
he meant there be no Loki Season three
and he was retiring from the Loki character
the way Robert Downey Jr and Chris Evans
kind of retired from Iron Man and Captain America.
But we know that they're coming back Recently,
the Loki producers
also said that there were more stories
to tell with the Loki character.
It would just depend on them finding a good one.
So even though right now
they're not like literally making Loki season three,
that doesn't mean that they won't do Loki.
Season three.
is that clever Hollywood speak for we're going to wait
and see how everything goes in the MCU
because we have big plans for Tom Hiddleston's
Loki during Avengers five in Avengers six.
So Tom Hiddleston will be back in a big character
in Avengers five next big question that everyone has.
Can he actually leave the chair?
Will the multiverse die if he leaves?
like he's sitting at the center here, the multiverse,
feeding all these timelines, his energy,
if he stops doing that, does
it mean that everything starts dying?
my assumption is they'll wait
till Avengers five to explain how he'll leave the chair
and it'll have something to do
with the new version of the Kang Multiverse War
that the Council of Kings
are going to start against The Avengers.
earlier this season I did a deleted scene video
about the storylines in scenes
that they were originally going to do
during Loki Season two, and one of the biggest ones
was a full on version of the Kang Multiverse War,
which they decided to save for Avengers five.
and because the multiverse now exists,
kind of like the grander celestial world
tree, there's a line from Norse mythology
about the world tree, about Ragnarok.
When the branches of the world tree shake, it's
meant to be a sign that Ragnarok is upon us again.
so my early theory is that at the beginning of Avengers
five or in some post-credits
scene in a movie right before it,
Loki will be sitting on his throne
and suddenly feel the Council of Kings
going around, erasing other timelines.
things will start to devolve into chaos.
Like the world tree, the celestial organization here
will start to go into chaos.
in. They'll give him a scene during Avengers five,
kind of like they gave
the Hulk during Infinity War,
where he's the one to warn Doctor Strange.
Some of the other Avengers characters
that the Council of Kings are coming for them
next big question people asking
when is he going to reunite with Thor?
The Loki producers did say that that was Marvel's
plan behind the scenes.
Like one of their big plans is to reunite Thor in Loki.
My only theory is that they'll probably save that
for Avengers five and it'll be like a big moment
then when he comes back to warn Thor.
But it also serves as a big reunion for the characters.
If we learn more about Loki Season
three, I'll do another video about it later this week.
But if they did, Loki, Season three would either happen
right before Secret Wars or after secret wars.
There are a couple clear points where they could retire
the Loki character for good if they want to.
But there are other characters like Kid Loki,
like there are ways to have versions
of Loki continue in the MCU if they want,
and there's always the Sylvie character to the breaking
to bring her back at some point in some story.
Eventually
Mobius was also supposed to be part of Deadpool three.
I don't know if that's changed,
so we'll see about that.
generally
they're just like a bunch of characters during Loki.
Like even miss Minutes
they tease might eventually go off the rails
and become a bigger villain in future stories
The TVA is also going to be a very big character
during Secret Wars, which is why they're basically
talked about going after the Council of Kings
monitoring the variants, quote unquote, of his remains,
which basically are the Council of Kings.
like.
They literally reference
Kang the Conqueror from Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania at the end of the episode.
It's like they're starting to focus
more specifically on that,
which is more of an Avengers five Avengers six teaser.
so within the context of the MCU,
like Loki is literally saving the MCU
but in real life he's also kind of metaphorically
carrying Marvel Studios
kind of saving Marvel, saving interest in the brand
with the non hardcore audience out there
they don't necessarily just tune in to everything
because it has a marvel name on it.
Loki is one of the best series
that Marvel has done since Disney Plus launch.
There are a couple of reasons
why that is in why so many of the series and movies.
Recently, it seemed like big misses for them.
end, even though there's some a luck that goes into
all these movies and series in their execution.
In reality,
there are some simple reasons why Loki has been
so much better and continued to be so popular. one.
Tom Hiddleston is probably one of the best actors
that they have inside any of these Marvel projects
too, playing one of the most well-developed characters
in the entire MCU.
He is a character that people have lived with
for the past 14 years,
a lot of Loki's popularity was able to grow organically
over the last 14 years
as opposed to a lot of other reason characters
that they tried to shoehorn in in C are popular,
make them feel like they're popular
or big parts of the Avengers stories,
but really they just kind of shoehorn them
in the last couple of years.
you can definitely feel
the difference between those two different concepts.
one of the other big reasons is that going into
making the Loki series, Marvel clearly
had a much better idea for who the Loki character was,
how they wanted to use him in how to write for him.
in even where there were occasional issues
with some of the writing or pacing some of the scenes.
Tom Hiddleston is such a fantastic actor.
He could just stand around reading the phone book
and make it look interesting.
He can turn anything into a good scene
no matter what they give him.
that's part of the magic of the Loki series,
like a lot of Marvel in general is built on
spectacle in the writing has always generally
been a little bit on the weak side
compared to like non big comic book movies.
Like other regular films like Christopher Nolan films,
for example, films where you can tell
they spent way more time developing scripts.
so that's part of the magic of the Loki series
is that a lot of their best moments were just Loki
and Mobius, or like Loki and other characters
standing around talking, not really
doing anything in Marvel didn't have to spend hundreds
of millions of dollars on the scene
because it wasn't a huge action
and it one of the jokes about some of the best
game of Thrones seasons in the early seasons
is it some of the best scenes?
Were them just having really, really good meetings,
sitting around a table?
you can kind of tell with a lot of other Marvel movies
and series, particularly this year
that Marvel just has way less of an idea
of what to do with the characters
or tell the right kind of story with them.
That's why reactions, for example, to the Marvel's
movie is so all over the map.
sometimes it just feels like Marvel has no idea
what to do with the Captain Marvel character
or how to make her vibe with the other Avengers
characters the same way that the original six felt
like a family that grew organically over time.
like that's why Avengers Infinity War in Avengers
Endgame hit so hard with those characters
because you lived with those characters for so long
they had all that time and all those movies to develop
those relationships between the six of them,
kind of the same thing with the Guardians of the Galaxy
characters, which was also one of the best movies
that Marvel did this year.
let me know in the comments, though,
how you think that Loki is saving the MCU, either
literally in the story or just metaphorically
in real life holding Marvel on his back.
thankfully, next year actually seems like the year
where Marvel starts to turn things around
and clean up a lot of the ongoing issues
it's been having the past year or two
there's only supposed to be one Marvel movie right
now, Deadpool
three in a couple series like X-Men 97,
what sounds like it's going to be pretty awesome.
The Echo series will also be coming in January.
It looks like it's actually going to be
just like the classic Daredevil series,
their couple other series next year
that we'll probably find out about soon.
generally,
Marvel is pulling way back and delaying stuff
so they have time to fix what they need to fix
so they don't have to rush stuff out the door,
which I think has been one of their problems
the last couple of years, is they're trying to rush
too much stuff out the door too quickly Don't worry.
I will do episode videos for whatever series,
whatever movies wind up coming out.
there were reports that what if season two will release
right before Christmas this year?
I'll do episode video so that we should get a trailer
pretty soon if it is going to come before Christmas.
the couple other big Loki videos that I'm working
on, I'll try to post those as soon as I can.
This week.
Big reminder to Invincible Season
two episodes Get started.
I'm doing videos for that.
It is probably one of the best comic books
there is just in general, not just animated series,
but best comic book series.
So be sure to check it out if you haven't seen it yet.
Congratulations Roddy
Wat Watt and Sugar Rush times.
You're the giveaway winners
from my last big Loki video.
Please email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
click.
Here for my full Loki Season 2 Episode 6
Finale video and click here for my Echo trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!